foreign
[Music]
ever since JK Rowling was caught in an
act of infidelity having an adulterous
affair with science the left has been
unable to really get over the Betrayal
they've been so enraged on such a such a
single-minded mission to punish JK
Rowling for her dalliance with common
sense that even those merely associated
with Rowling are made to perform acts of
public Penance the entire cast of the
Harry Potter film series have come out
at various points and uh you know they
want to make it clear that that they do
not share Rowling's heretical belief in
biology you know they've been desperate
to Signal their allegiance to the trans
cult we're not like her they cry as they
humble themselves before the LGBT God
we're good and Faithful Servants we what
other basic realities would you like for
us to deny what other bits of
nonsensical gibberish do you need us to
utter on your behalf
well we could put out a statement saying
that two plus two equals green elephants
are made of pudding if you want anything
for you o Lords
Chief among these gravelers is Harry
Potter himself Daniel Radcliffe who um
you know clearly recognizes that he is
potentially the most guilty the most
Guilty By Association as the star of
Rowling's fantasy series he feels called
to speak the loudest about this he must
do the most to repudiate the author's
bigoted belief in reality the result is
that Radcliffe has now taken a public
position that is even more fictional and
Fantastical than the world of wizards
that Rowling created I mean if Radcliffe
had come out and announced that Hogwarts
is a real place where actual children
fly on broomsticks and learn how to do
magical spells it would have been less
outrageous and more credible than the
position he's actually taken
because instead he's professed uh to
believe in transgenderism especially
trans kids quote unquote recently he sat
down for a Roundtable discussion with
these alleged trans kids in a video
produced by the left-wing extremist
group The Trevor Project watch
I learned from you know
out of the cradle that I am you know
that I was a boy I should like blue I
should like sports I should be manly I
should like superheroes yeah and I just
I never associate myself with those
things and we are told that we're not
old enough to know to know this yet like
I mean I'm only 11 years old how do I
know I'm a girl and I need more time to
think about this
he doesn't like blue sports or
superheroes
that's how we know he's a girl
it's not how he decided that he's a girl
I mean he's a child he didn't decide
anything rather it's how the adults in
his life decided for him
so we see once again how the the only
people rigidly enforcing so-called
gender roles are the gender ideologues
themselves they are such Believers and
Generals they so firmly insist that boys
must must like boy things quote unquote
that anybody anybody who doesn't like
those things is labeled a Girl by them
this is uh you know gender role
reinforcement taken to grotesque
extremes
is something that the most Avid
right-wing believer in gender roles
never would have even considered
I myself believe in gender roles that is
I believe that there are certain roles
certain attitudes and behaviors that
Society should expect from a person
based on their sex I believe that that
doesn't mean that someone who rejects
those roles isn't a member of the sex
anymore
also when I talk about gender roles I
mean like more important things like we
should teach boys how to be protectors
and providers you know that kind of
General I couldn't care less if they
like superheroes or the color blue
who gives a damn about that
so the gender ideologue not only
ruthlessly and violently enforces gender
roles but in forces specifically the
most Superfluous and meaningless ones
by the way I know something about boys
who don't care about sports or
superheroes I'm raising two of them
right now
both of my older Sons are are only you
know nominally interested in superheroes
and neither of them have shown any great
interest in sports aside from you know
shooting Hoops out of the in the
driveway on occasion but uh my
nine-year-old son prefers to build forts
in the woods that's what he likes to do
my six-year-old prefers to follow his
older brother around and annoy him with
whatever he's doing that's basically his
hobby right now
um what's the significance of their lack
of interest in sports and superheroes
there is no significance it doesn't
matter
okay I mean I I'm as conservative as you
can get when it comes to these issues
right and I embraced that like I said I
I embrace the fact that I oh gender we
don't want gender roles I fully Embrace
gender rules I think they're a good
thing
but even I with my own Sons I'm not like
well you need you sit down and watch
Batman you have to watch you have to
like Batman you're a boy
I don't do that nobody does that
okay nobody cares that much about it
there are many ways to be a boy this
this is the truly accepting view of the
matter
so it's the left who declares that there
is only one way and any boy who exists
in any other way is kicked out of the
boy club
let's continue
but there are also people who do have
like a slightly condescending but
well-meaning attitude of like well
people are young and like how do we you
know there is a huge decision I'd love
to hear from all of you about like why
we can trust kids to like tell us who
they are
like well we
and you kind of share like a similar
story I transitioned like super young I
came out to my mom and well not telling
her I was trans but told her that I was
a girl at the age of six it's been like
years like what I've lived female more
than I've ever lived male so like I just
feel like it's just living proof that I
obviously knew who I was just like
everyone else does
I don't understand why I can't just
decide that I'm a girl I if it's a big
decision to decide on my girl it's a big
decision to decide I'm a boy right it's
just it's the same thing there's no
there's no age you don't have to be 18
to decide that oh I am who I am I think
we don't give children enough credit for
coming into this world and having a
sense of Purity and understanding for
themselves like
um I definitely had that at a very young
age and I tried to express that a lot
but I grew up in like a very
stereotypically Christian family okay so
like me telling my mom any type of me
being different was like oh my God like
literally she called my grandma and they
prayed over me I was like seven
and like at that very moment like it was
very like fearful like fear striking but
like at the same time if we're going to
be able to like have relationships and
be authentic with each other this is
something that I need you all to get you
know yeah but I would love to hear from
you also about just like as I said like
I always knew I was a boy because it was
just a thing that I grew up knowing yeah
yeah
um so everything that these kids are
saying is is nonsense it's gibberish one
of the kids says that the fact that he
announced his fictional female identity
when he was sick somehow proves that
it's legitimate but I believe this when
I was six is not a convincing defense
for literally any proposition
six-year-olds believe lots of things
about the world and themselves that are
not so this is one of the Hallmarks of
Early Childhood it also has been one of
the most you know has been had been one
of the most charming and joyful things
about childhood the fact that kids are
so innocent and oblivious
but the left has exploited the citizens
in the most Insidious kind of way the
other boy says that choosing to
transition into a girl
isn't a big decision any more than it
would be a big decision to choose to
remain a boy that's like saying that a
nine-year-old choosing to be a
commercial airline pilot isn't any more
of a big decision than choosing to not
be a commercial airline pilot just
because one decision is Big doesn't mean
that the reverse of that decision is
also big
of course my analogy doesn't totally
work because it is at least technically
possible for a nine-year-old to Pilot a
plane it's not a good idea but it's
possible it's not possible for a
nine-year-old or for anyone of any age
to become the opposite sex so again this
is all nonsensical but I don't judge
these children obviously or feel any you
know uh contempt towards them they're
abuse victims they've been brainwashed
they've been LED down a path and they've
been made to believe that it's a path
they chose and now they are offering
retroactive justifications for this path
that was actually chosen for them and
they're not justifications that they
came up with but rather they are talking
points that they were given and that
they were told to repeat on occasions
like this
so I have an immense amount of sympathy
for these kids
but Daniel Radcliffe on the other hand
is a different story now notice how
Radcliffe ever so meekly pushes back and
attentively suggesting that maybe
somebody might raise and arguably
somewhat valid concern about you know
whether children are old enough to make
these kinds of decisions it's totally
patronizing of course he hastens Dad
it's patronizing and they're wrong for
saying it but but uh but you know I mean
how should we respond to these questions
yeah I mean listen Daniel you you know
better
you're only a few years younger than me
you grew up in a world where the
biological reality of male and female
was not in question which is the same
role that every generation of human
beings except the most recent one grew
up in
so they didn't get to you soon enough or
young enough for you to actually buy
this garbage you cannot have been
convinced because nobody's ever
presented an argument in defense of this
stuff it's not that they've made bad
arguments is that they've made no
arguments
so there was never a moment when someone
came along and said to you hey you know
actually little boys can really be girls
and and we should give them drugs to
make them into girls even though they
already are girls but they're girls
invisibly you see and so they're girls
in some kind of uh you know in some sort
of abstract sense and that's what we
need the drugs for
and and then and then and then no one
said that to you and then you said oh
well that makes sense okay I mean you've
convinced me
no that didn't happen because they
mostly sane and moderately intelligent
person cannot be persuaded by
unintelligible gibberish
so there can't be any I get it moment
because there's nothing to get you
weren't convinced by arguments or by any
kind of reasoning process
you were instead like most other adults
on the left convinced in the same way
that you know a um a shop owner in the
1940s would have been convinced to
accept the protection of the mob the mob
doesn't come to a business and present a
proposal a business proposal and then
you know give you a week to weigh the
pros and cons
they extract your compliance through
threat and force
and that is exactly how the LGBT mob
operates
you have been encouraged to promote the
trans agenda encouraged with the promise
that if you don't they'll rip your life
to shreds and and also your career
it's been hard enough for the Harry
Potter guy to get any good roles outside
of the Harry Potter franchise imagine
how hard it would be if the Harry Potter
guy was also a transphobe
so that's the calculation that you made
you may take comfort in the fact that
you're only going along with this
Sinister Madness because you feel you
have no other choice but you should
realize that every era has its own sort
of sinister Madness and every person uh
who's ever gone along with it has made
the exact same rationalization that you
are making now
and yet we look back on those people
with disgust
they were faced with a test
stand for what's right and true and
endure the consequences or cooperate
with evil for the sake of their own
self-preservation and they fail the test
and they're defined forever and for all
time by that failure just as you will be
you sat in a room full of child abuse
victims and you applauded their abuse
you are a disgrace and a coward and a
liar
you sold whatever fragments of your soul
you still had left
I hope it was worth it but I know that
it wasn't
because again it never is
and that's why you are today
canceled and that'll do it for the show
or for this portion shows move over to
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you on Monday have a great
weekend Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]